[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club le
retour de Benjamin Morel bonjour
Benjamin merci d'être là ça va vous ça
va très bien et Arnaud toujours fidèle
au PO bonjour AR bén merci d'être avec
ns rédacteur en chef de la revue
Politique est parlementaire on va parler
avec vous du plan antimeut qui a été
présenté hier par Elisabeth B placée
sous le signe de la fermeté avec
plusieurs mesures notamment renforcement
des sanctions pénales une
responsabilisation des parents et les
maires qui doivent être mis au cœur du
dispositif on va parler de tout ça et
puis on parlera également de la loi
immigration puisque Samia vous allez
nous refaire le feuilleton de la semaine
oui he qui a beaucoup beaucoup occupé la
classe politique cette semaine
exactement on va en parler on parle
d'ailleurs tout de suite de géralde
armanin c'est l'actualité dans nos
régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos région avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
a retrouver agès Briançon bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
journaliste au dehiné libéré et Gérald
harmanin qui est donc du côté de chez
vous aujourd'hui pour un déplacement sur
le thème de l'immigration et notamment
de l'immigration illégale entre la
France et la
Suisse on a un petit problème de
connexion annès Briançon on va essayer
de vous retrouver dans quelques secondes
et de rétablir la connexion je crois
qu'on vous a retrouvé agès je sais pas
si vous si vous m'avez entendu pour nous
parler de ce déplacement de Gérald
daranin en effet Gérald d'Anin est
attendu en haut de sa voie cet
après-midi il devait arrivver dès ce
matin à ANC mais il y a eu un changement
de programme dans la nuit donc il sera
cet après-midi en en haut de Savoie à la
frontière au niveau de Gaillard pourquoi
ce déplacement tout simplement parce que
Ben la frontière Suisse c'est 63 points
de passage entre la France et la Suisse
et une immigration irrégulière qui est
en hausse il a annoncé plus de 23 % de
situation irrégulière à la frontière
depuis un an un doublement des refus de
passage par les douaniers en un an
également donc comme il y a 11 points
qui concernent la Haute Savoie il est
important pour lui de créer cet accord
bilatéral qui va mener tout simplement à
la création de patrouilles mixes
c'est-à-dire des policiers français et
suisses qui vont patrouiller ensemble
des zones de jonction où ils pourront
échanger également des informations et
également un volet qui va permettre
d'éloigner ensemble les les personnes en
situation irrégulière ça a déjà commencé
le 10 octobre dernier un vol
franco-suisse a emmené des Géorgiens
dans leur pays d'origine et puis Gérald
haranin il vous accorde une interview ce
matin dans laquelle il revient sur le
projet de loi immigration et plus
particulièrement sur la régularisation
des travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tenstion en effet dans cette
interview assez large il revient sur cet
article auquel il croit beaucoup auquel
il tient beaucoup également il n'hésite
pas à parler de d'immigration choisie et
ciblée aujourd'hui il veut faire rentrer
en France des personnes qui vont
travailler qui vont étudier qui ne vont
pas attaquer le pacte républicain il
fait aussi de la pédagogie en rappelant
que cette loi immigration ce n'est pas
un appel d'air et cette régularisation
des des des centres des travailleurs
sans papierers dans les métiers en
tenstion ce n'est pas un appel d'air
c'est un effet très restrictif puisquil
faut être là depuis plus de 3 ans avoir
travaillé plus de 24 mois dans ses
métiers en tension euh ne pas avoir de
casier judiciaire mais également ce
titre de séjour d'un an n'ouvre pas
droit au regroupement familial donc tout
ça il explique et il assume que bah
désormais on choisira si cette loi passe
mais il est prêt également il le dit à
discuter bien évidemment de cet article
de l'ensemble des 48 qui figure dans la
loi immigration merci merci beaucoup AG
cette interview de géralde haranin est à
lire évidemment ce matin dans le
Dauphiné on regarde votre une plan
antiémeut ce que borne a annoncé c'est à
la Une de votre journal merci d'avoir
été avec nous agès nous en parler on va
évidemment revenir sur cette loi
immigration puisque ça aussi fait partie
de l'actualité de la semaine et Samia
pour faire le le film vous allez nous
rembobiner le film de la semaine
feuilleton politique autour de ce projet
de loi immigration ça a commencé
dimanche dernier oui par un article dans
Le Journal du Dimanche Gérald harmanin
laisse entendre que l'article ticle 3 du
projet de loi immigration pourrait
disparaître l'article 3 c'est celui qui
prévoit la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension la droite sénatoriale
n'en veut pas elle en a même fait une
ligne rouge et elle menace de ne pas
voter le texte sauf que pour faire
adopter le texte au Sénat et bien
justement le gouvernement a besoin des
voix de la droite sénatoriale alors
Gérald harmanin a fait un pas vers elle
en déclarant je cite je suis évidemment
prêt à en discuter l'heure est assez
grave pour que l'on ait des compromis
sur des choses qui ne sont pas centrales
et quelques jours plus tard dans Le
Parisien le Parisien pardon estû
qu'Élisabeth bande serait sur la même
ligne oui le journal rapporte des propos
tenus lors d'un dîner entre la première
ministre et Bruno rotaillot le patron
des sénateurs de droite ellisabeth borne
lui aurait dit qu'elle aussi est prête à
retirer cet article 3 sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier rectification de Bruno rotillot
elle n'a pas tout à fait dit ça mais
franchement on n'est pas très loin de la
vérité regarde
première chose elle ne m'a pas dit
qu'elle allait retirer l'article 3 de ce
texte oui deuxième chose elle m'a
clairement dit que l'article 3 ça
n'était pas son choix ça sonne donc
comme un désave pourquoi parce que elle
m'a confirmer que cette idée folle cette
idée folle de créer un droit automatique
à la régularisation des clandestins ça
n'était pas une bonne idée alors le
problème pour Elisabeth borne c'est qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale une parti des
députés de sa majorité tient au
contraire fermement à garder cet article
3 sur la régularisation des travailleurs
sans papier c'est l'elle gauche du camp
macroniste qui veut garder le côté
humain d'un texte par ailleurs assez dur
sur la question des expulsions
d'étrangers d'après une information du
Figaro des députés de renaissance ont
écrit à la première ministre cette
semaine pour lui demander à être reçu
rapidement sur le sujet parmi eux
sachaoulier qui jure que l'article 3
sera maintenu regardez je suis certain
puisque s'il ne l'est pas au Sénat nous
le réintroduirons à l'Assemblée
nationale là où il faut être très clair
là il faut être c'est qu'il faut juger
il faut juger les étrangers pour ce
qu'ils font et pas pour ce qu'ils sont
on ne les juge pas parce qu'ils sont
étrangers on les juge parce que soit ils
sont délinquants ils n'ont rien à faire
sur le territoire national nous devons
les renvoyer et être extrêmement ferme
soit ce sont des travailleurs qui
cherchent à s'intégrer qui souvent font
l'objet d'appui de parlementaire aussi
de droite aussi de droite il faut le
dire ce sont ces mêmes parlementaires de
droite qui écrivent parfois ministre de
l'Intérieur pour demander leur
régularisation donc et alors Sam bien la
question qu'on se pose c'est est-ce
qu'un compromis peut être trouvé pour
faire adopter ce texte alors la
droiteelle elle propose de laisser les
préfets régulariser les travailleurs
sans papier au cas par cas ellisabeth
borne y est favorable pour ça du coup il
n'aurait pas forcément besoin d'en
passer par la loi mais si on met rien du
tout sur les régularisations dans cette
loi immigration ça risque aussi de
bloquer pour tous ceux qui veulent un
texte équilibré c'est le cas des
centristes du Sénat qui ne sont pas
d'ailleurs d'accord sur ce sujet avec
leurs alliés de droite et ils appellent
tout le monde au compromis regardez les
républicains sont d'accord avec nous
pour dire on peut rectifier tout ça par
voie circulaire c'est la circulaire Vals
on la rectifie bon très bien le seul
point le seul point c'est que dans
l'article dans un article de la loi
l'article 3 ou un autre on puisse dire
qu'on va changer la
circulaire parce qu'à l'Assemblée il y a
des gens qui vous disent s'il y a pas ça
on vote pas et eux ils disent si on le
met on vote pas problème c'est de savoir
si on veut ou si on veut pas que ce
texte soit voté ça c'est un autre sujet
mais il faut assumer à ce moment-là
qu'on arrête toutes ces palidonies sur
un malheureux article qui mérite pas
tout ça alors petit point vocabulaire
une palinedie c'est un changement
d'opinion merci à Hervé Marseille pour
ce nouveau mot dans notre répertoire
bref vous le voyez sur ce sujet le c'est
très compliqué hein pour le gouvernement
qui est pris en tenaille entre la droite
sénatoriale et une partie de sa majorité
l'assemblée ça pour ce résumé de la
semaine Arnaud c'est un feuon en
rebondissement cette histoire d'article
ou mais tout a été dit en l'occurrence
parce que en fait vous avez parfaitement
décrit la l'équation parlementaire qui
est extrêmement compliquée de toute
façon le problème c'est que si
finalement la position de la majorité
sénatoriale enfin en tout cas du groupe
LR est retenu on voit bien les problèmes
que ça posera à l'Assemblée nationale
parce que vous avez une partie de l'aile
gauche qu'on appelle l'aile gauche de la
macronie qui aujourd'hui milite pour le
maintien de cet article 3 sachat oulier
le président de la commission des lois
l'a rappelé à plusieurs reprises
d'ailleurs il avait cossigné une tribune
je rappelle au mois d'août fin août avec
des parlementaires de la nupes sur ce
sur ce sujet moi je ne vois pas à ce
stade euh mais peut-être que Benjamin
affirmera mes propos je ne vois pas à ce
stade comment l'exécutif peut faire
adopter ce texte sans euh user du 493
donc ça me paraît ça me paraît presque
un inscrit dans l'histoire à ce stade
sauf évolution majeure parce que les
républicains n'ont pas intérêt dans le
climat actuel et sur un sujet aussi
sensible que
l'immigration de faire des concessions à
la majorité présidentielle donc tout ça
rend extrêmement difficile l'adoption du
texte mais après la seule question qui
se pose la seule question qui est
intéressante sur le plan parlementaire
et sur le plan politique c'est de savoir
si les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale IR ront jusqu'au bout de leur
opposition et aller jusqu'au bout de son
opposition à un moment donné et ben
c'est de déposer une motion de censure
là on pas encore là là ce sera un autre
feu ton ça bien are feu voilà Benjamin
vous affirmez ou vous confirmez non je
confirme en effet on est souvent
d'accord avec au sauf quand on parle
d'une petite île de la
Méditerranée non il y a deux angles
d'analyse le premier angle d'analyse
c'est en effet les rapports entre
majorités souvenez-vous du dernier
quinena le premier moment où la majorité
à l'époque préorique d'Emmanuel Macron
se divise c'est sur la loi immigr
il y a au sein de cette majorité de
vraie tension sur le sujet et en effet
si jamais le texte se fait aux
conditions de LR il emportera pas la vie
de sa chouillé voir même de certains hom
modème ça va être plus large et donc
qu'est-ce qui va se passer à ce
moment-là si on a un 49 àine à 3 ce sera
pas un 49 àine à 3 comme sur le budget
ça sera un 49 àina 3 que vous ferez
contre une partie de votre majorité et
ça déjà que votre majorité est
déstructurée et aujourd'hui en fin de
règne c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
violent hein souvenez-vous François
Hollande les frondeurs les 49 aliné à 3
contre les frondeurs et cetera on loi
Macron loi le comerie c'est un peu le
même scénario donc vous comprenez toutes
les divisions que ça peut créer alors
qu'on est encore à 3 ans des prochaines
présidentielles et qu'il faut tenir avec
une majorité relative donc cette loi
pour ça elle risque de laisser des
traces le deuxième élément et
l'intervention d' RV Marseille est
extrêmement intéressante on en est à se
demander comment est-ce qu'on va prévoir
dans la loi la possibilité d'avoir une
circulaire le juriste vous dirait que et
ben ça veut dire que votre loi elle est
en grande partie inutile
fondamentalement on a une loi sur
l'immigration tous les 3 ans le problème
aujourd'hui n'est pas la loi le problème
c'est l'application de la loi c'est la
question du rapport avec le droit
européen c'est la question parce que moi
je bien qu'on revienne sur la circulaire
Val c'est quand même priant en
application d'une directive donc c'est
ça le problème de l'autre côté vous avez
mon TF elle est bien gentille mais si
jamais j'ai pas laisser passer
consulaire je peux avoir une nouvelle
loi ça fera pas changer d'avis le
gouvernement d'Alger sur mon laisser
passer consulaire et enfin bah il y a en
effet des soucis d'organisation
administrative on peut envisager de
modifier certains actes règlementaire
mais ça passe pas d'abord par la loi je
dis pas qu'il y aura rien dans cette loi
qu'elle sera pas tout à fait utile mais
on voit que là-dessus la loi est quand
même est plus d'affichage pour donner le
nom d'un ministre à cette toit en
question si jamais la majorité explose
en vol pour ça ça montrera où on est
tombé la politique est-ce que l'erreur
du gouvernement à l'origine parce que ça
fait des mois que ça dure en réalité he
cette cette impossibilité de trouver un
compromis est-ce que l'erreur ce n'est
pas d'avoir voulu présenter un seul
texte alors que si finalement le
gouvernement a présenté deux textes un
un pour la partie plus dure et un pour
la partie dite plus humaine il aurait
peut-être pu faire adopter les deux bah
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait dans d'autres
domaines notamment sur l'énergie par
exemple il y a eu le texte nucléire où
il y a le texte énergie renouvelable ça
marche à condition que tout le monde
veut bien faire comme si ça devait
marcher c'est-à-dire une partie de la
majorité se dit d'accord je vote ce
texte et je me cache les yeux sur
l'autre et les les LR font pareil sur un
sujet aussi vouleit pas parce qu'il
voulait pas de saissonnage exement sur
un sujet aussi clivant aussi
politiquement lié à l'identité politique
de LR aujourd'hui qui a besoin de se
démarqué de la majorité ça aurait été
quand même assez compliqué ouais est-ce
en oui enfin il y a deux sujets si vous
voulez au-delà des des problèmes de de
technique parlementair qui sont réels et
qui sont très importants moi je crois
qu'il y a deux sujets fondamentaux le
premier sujet Benjamin l'a l'a évoqué
c'est que finalement cette loi c'est une
loi qui est quand même fortement
contrainte par un certain nombre de
normes qui à ce stade nous échappe et je
rappelle quand même que la proposition
des républicains et la proposition la
plus forte des républicains la position
matrice c'est la possibilité de
soumettre à référendum la question
migratoire ce qui n'est pas possible
dans l'état actuel de la Constitution et
qui nécessite une révision
constitutionnelle donc ça c'est quand
même un sujet qui est un sujet majeur si
l'on veut véritablement traiter au fond
la question migratoire le deuxième sujet
c'est l'opinion publique moi je
j'entends ce que dit Hervé Marseille
mais je serais très intéressé
d'interroger les Français sur l'article
3 on peut pas le faire mais je ser très
intéressé qu'il y ait par exemple une
étude d'opinion sur l'article 3 je ne
suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui une majorité
de Français soit favorable à cet article
3 en l'occurrence parce que qu'est-ce
qui se passe on a un durcissement de
l'opinion publique sur l'enjeu
migratoire ce durcissement c'est un
durcissement qu'on voit croître se
développer depuis de très nombreuses
années mais qui aujourd'hui arrive
quasiment à son point d'acmé ce qui
explique la position des républicains
au-delà que ça fasse partie de leur ADN
c'est le fait aussi qu'ils sont tout à
fait conscient que il y a une évolution
aujourd'hui de l'opinion publique sur la
question migratoire qui demande de la
fermeté qui demande l'autorité et qui
demande très clairement de la
restriction mais sauf que géralde
haranin elle dit que la fermeté elle est
dans cette loi est-ce que est-ce que
mais est-ce que le contexte ne va pas
coincer les républicains est-ce que
l'opinion publique comprendrait que les
républicains fassent échouer cette loi à
ce stade si vous voulez je regardais une
étude
d'opinion je crois de l'institut odoxa
qui est pas qui a été publié la semaine
dernière la façon dont les Français
jugent déjà la
politique migratoire du gouvernement il
la juge de manière assez sévère
majoritairement quand on les interroge
même s'ils ont certainement pas lu le
texte de loi le le projet le projet
quand on les interroge sur finalement la
le projet de loi présenté par Gérald
dermanin il considère qu'il est
insuffisant même si même si il valide un
certain nombre j'allais dire d'articles
de ce projet qui semble à leurs yeux
aller dans le bon sens
mais globalement quand même quand on
voit l'état de l'opinion c'est un état
de l'opinion qui demande beaucoup plus
encore une fois d'autorité de F il y a
un autre article dont on parle peu enfin
il y a une autre proposition dont on
parle peu qui est une proposition
sénatoriale et qui risque de faire qui
risque de poser problème également c'est
la transformation de l'aide
médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence et là aussi ça devrait faire
et ça a déjà fait bondir la l' gauche de
de la macronie à l'Assemblée mais g
soutient oui et alors je rejoins tout à
fait ce que disait Arnaud et ça rejoint
également une remarque que je faisais
qui m'a paraît importante on a eu 29
lois depuis 1980 sur l'immigration en
moyenne une toutes les 3 ans comment
est-ce que ça se passe en réalité ces
loi ne changeent pas fondamentalement la
donne j'arrive en tant que ministre je
fais passer une nouvelle loi et je la
vend très très bien je dis cette loi va
tout changer demain il n'y aura plus de
sujet d'immigration évidemment c'est pas
vrai 3 ans plus tard on en a une
nouvelle aujourd'hui il y a une un
sentiment de l'assitude de l'opinion
est-ce que le politique peut encore en
la matière est-ce que le politique
serait en capacité sur ce sujet de
reprendre le contrôle pour les raisons
que j'ai évoqué c'est pas si évident et
là où j'ai une divergence avec Arnaud
c'est que le référendum ne changera rien
votre loi vottere par référendum h c'est
toujours une loi elle est toujours
soumise à la hiérarchie des normes votre
loi soumise au référendum ben elle fera
pas non plus avancer la question de
laisser passer consulaire donc si jamais
on arrive à un référendum sur
l'immigration quoi qu'on va mettre
dedans oui non pas bien c'est pas une
position sur le fond mais euh elle ne
sera pas plus efficace que les autres en
réalité tant qu'on ne pense sera pas
justement efficacité de la loi et de
l'autre côté hiérarchie des normes on se
contentera d'avoir une opinion qui dit
bah oui oui là il y a quelque chose
qu'on va faire et qui le lendemain et
ben finira grogy et qui demandera du
coup une forme de surencha politique
sauf que la position initiale des
républiain quand ils ont présenté je
dire leur contreprosition au projet de
loi gouvernementale c'était d'essayer de
faire bouger la hiérarchie des normes
mais le problème c'est que je veux dire
ils se retrouvent un peu coincés
j'allais dire dans leur dans leur dans
leur européanisme et et qui le souci de
on déroge entre guillemets ce qui est
très différent de ce que font les Danois
avec un système d'optout où on sort des
traités sur certains aspects euh le
problème de la dérogation c'est que la
Commission européenne peut pas
l'accepter parce que l'Union européenne
c'est pas un état l'Union européenne
c'est un ordre juridique Vous dérogez à
ce moment-là c'est l' c'est l'ensemble
du système qui s'effondre on va parler
d'une autre actualité de cette semaine
hier ellizabeth borne et une partie de
son gouvernement dont Gérald harmanin on
va y venir présenter les réponses
régaliennes devant des centaines de ma
réponse régalienne 4 mois après les
émeutes des mesures placées sous le
signe de la fermeté audre
vietaz pour les maires des communes
touchées par les violences urbaines d'il
y a 4 mois la facture peut s'avérer
mirobolante bâtiment à reconstruire bus
à racheter alors Elisabeth borne annonce
un fond de 100 millions d'euros pour
aider à la reconstruction en complément
de l'indemnisation des assurances pour
le reste elle joue la carte de la
fermeté avec des sanctions pour les
mineurs hauteurs de violences urbaines
dans certains cas nous pouvons envisager
un encadrement de jeunes délinquants par
des militaires qui pourront notamment
transmettre des valeurs de discipline et
de dépassement de soie les parents sont
aussi mis à contribution financièrement
en cas de dégradation et ils devront
réaliser des travaux d'intérêt général
ou des stages de responsabilité
parentale du côté des sanctions pénales
l'amende pour violation du couvre-feu
devrait passer de 150 à 750 €.
l'exécutif veut aussi permettre aux
police municipal de réaliser certains
actes de police judiciaire une mesure
déjà présente dans le projet de loi
sécurité globale mais retoqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel le ministre de
l'intérieur propose donc une autre
solution qui consisterait à discuter
avec les maires de France association
des Mair de France pour voir ceux qui
veulent rentrer de manière volontaire
dans un dispositif où on pourrait
agrandir très fortement les pouvoirs de
police de la police municipale les
réactions des maires en première ligne
sont partagées on a senti dans la salle
que ça faisait plaisir aux collègues
maire parce que oui c'est pas normal
qu'en France un policier municipal
puisse être armé dans la rue mais ne
puisse pas ouvrir un coffre puisse pas
faire une palpation un contrôle
d'identité et avoir accès au fichiers
des immatriculations c'est un non sens
il va y avoir si on met le doigt
là-dedans une inégalité en matière de
sécurité de tranquillité publique en
clair les
villes financièrement bien doté qui vont
pouvoir se payer une police de dingue et
puis celles qui ont peu ou pas de moyens
qui ne vont pas pouvoir voir suivre le
rythme et fondamentalement où est-ce
qu'il y a moins de police on le sait
tous dans les quartiers prioritaires de
la ville dernière annonce le
gouvernement crée une force d'action
républicaine une brigade composée de
magistrats de policiers et de médiateurs
afin d'apporter des réponse spécifique à
un quartier en cas d'émeut des
expérimentations seront menées à
Besançon Valence et maobug Arnaud des
réponses hier clairement placé sous le
signe de la fermeté par ellisabeth Bor
pas oui il le fallait certainement alors
est-ce que c'est jugé suffisant je ne
suis pas sûr vu les réactions d'un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques notamment à droite à l'issue
de de cette de cet exercice il fallait
envoyer desion évidemment à l'opinion
publique encore une fois mais aussi au
maires et aux élus locaux qui ont été en
première ligne lors de ces lors de ces
émeutes moi ce qui me frappe quand même
c'est que si vous voulez ce qui est
toujours très difficile en terme de
lisibilité lorsquil y a ce type
d'annonce c'est la multiplication si
vous voulez des mesures il y a une
multiplication des mesures en fait quand
vous lisez ce qu'il propose vous avez
une espèce d'inventaire quasiment à la
prévre de tout un ensemble de mesures de
fermeté dont on peut quand même se poser
la question de la pertinence sur la
durée et surtout sur la faisabilité pour
certaines d'entre elles donc on verra
bien quelque part et et parmi les
mesures euh il y a le fait de donner
plus de pouvoir aux police municipal on
a entendu Philippe rioot dans dans le
sujet il était notre invité il y a
quelques minutes euh craindre un une
américanisation de la police et de
craindre des inégalités territoriales
entre les communes qui auront les moyens
de se payer une police municipale très
dotée et celles qui ne pourront pas et
ils le disent celles qui ne pourront pas
c'est celles qui en ont le plus besoin
c'est celles qui ont des des quartiers
prioritaires c'est le problème mais
c'est déjà le cas en partie avec la
vidéosurveillance vous savez alors là il
y a des aides notamment des régions si
vous voyez ce qui se fait en
île-de-fance il y a une volonté de
financer les communes qui vont être et
l'État aussi hein que Gman dire que
c'était pas utilisé par les ma alors en
effet il y a une possibilité de financer
de la vidéosurveillance dans des
communes qui sont un peu moins doté mais
on connaît l'état aujourd'hui des
inégalités territoriales c'est-à-dire
que si vous avez un certain nombre de
leviers qui vous permettent de dynamiser
votre territoire et que vous avez des
revenus suffisant vous pouvez vous
permettre d'avoir une super police vous
pouvez vous permettre d'avoir de la
vidéosurveillance résultat ceux qui vont
se sentir en insécurité ailleurs que
vont-ils faire ils vont venir habiter
chez vous notamment les plus riches qui
on on les moyens ce qui va encore vous
rajouter des revenus de l'autre côté et
bien vous allez boire des communes ou
qui vont être au contraire pour cette
raisonl fuit et qui donc auront moins de
auront moins de moyens donc là il y a un
vrai risque on peut en par il compenser
à travers la péréquation on peut en
partie le compenser en ayant une vraie
politique d'aménagement de développement
territorial et d'aide aux communes qui
voudrai mener ce type de projet
seulement le problème c'est que c'est
bien beau sur le papier de l'envisager
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
quand même des collectivités qui sont à
l'os et un état qui ne peut guerre les
aider parce que il y a des critères de
convergence budgétaire donc si on s'en
donne les moyens oui si on s'en donne
pas les moyens bah en effet on aura
encore un peu plus demain qu'aujourd'hui
de France et de France qui là-dessus ne
seront plus plus du tout jugé à la même
enseigne ouais est-ce qu'il faut pas
aussi changer peut-être la philosophie
de la politique de la ville parce que
eléisabeth borne et Géral armanin l'ont
rappelé hier la la réponse aux émeutes
elle dépasse largement la question des
quartiers et des banlieux c'est ce
qu'ils ont dit et il rappelit que les
quartiers concernés par les émeutes du
début de l'été tous n'étaient pas des
quartiers en politique de la ville et
que il y avait des villes avec des
quartiers en politique de la ville qui
avaient pas été concernés et à contrari
des villes moyennes sans quartiers
prioritaires qui avaient été touché par
ces émeutes oui parce que si vous voulez
je pense qu'aussi d'une certaine manière
la politique de la ville qui a été
pensée dans les années 90 euh la
doctrine de la politique de la ville
telle qu'elle a été pensée dans les
années 90 n'a pas évolué
vraisemblablement par rapport aux
évolutions sociologique et notamment
territoriale évidemment la France s'est
modifiée depuis les années 90 donc il
faut vra c'est vrai que ce qui était
frappant dans ces émeut c'est que vous
avez des villes moyennes en province
parfois dans ce qu'on appelle la France
périphérique qui ont été extrêmement
touchés par le phénomène hmetier donc la
nécessité en effet de repenser peut-être
les aides
s'impose après vous savez moi ce que je
constate aussi c'est que quand même
encore une fois il faut quand même
toujours se poser la question de
l'opinion publique et de la relation à
la Société des politiques publiques
c'est que globalement ce qui se
diffracte quand même dans la société
dans l'opinion public a tort ou à raison
peu importe mais c'est la réalité du
sentiment et on fait de la politique
aussi parfois avec les sentiments
collectifs malheureusement c'est ainsi
c'est que beaucoup a été fait pour la
politique de la ville même si c'est jugé
insuffisant par les acteurs locaux et
que finalement la réponse qui s'impose
c'est la réponse de fermeté et
d'autorité de rétablissement de l'ordre
républicain finalement on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui le le le l'exécutif mais
c'est pas propre à Emmanuel Macron
c'était propre aux exécutifs précédents
en l'occurrence et toujours si vous
voulez pris entre la nécessité
d'arbitrer entre une jambe droite qui
est une jambe plutôt régalienne et une
jambe gauche qui est plutôt sociale mais
que finalement cette politique au aux
yeux là aussi de de nombre de nos
compatriotes apparaît pour une grande
partie
illisible pour terminer peut-être sur
une question plus politique est-ce que
dans les deux thème qu'on a évoqué la lo
immigration et le plan antimut on est
aussi sur un match sur une rivalité
entre Gérald haranin et ellisabeth borne
bah il y a une façon en effet pour le
ministre de l'intérieur dont la
stratégie se calque plus ou moins sur
celle de Nicolas Sarkozi d'exister de
sur exister sur ces thèmes et donc là
évidemment dès le moment où vous avez
des séquences médiatiques il en profite
ellisabeth borne elle elle a une autre
problématique elle doit gérer cette
majorité totalement des compositions
qu'on évoqué tout à l'heure il faut que
elle est certes Géral armanin mais il
faut également qu'elle ait sachaouillé
parce que il fin si vous avez une
majorité qui se distend c'est elle qui
est sur la Salette et c'est elle qui a
toute la nécessité de la maintenir c'est
son rôle c'est son but elle est nommée
pour ça et donc forcément au-delà des
ambitions personnelles des uns et des
autres et bien les objectifs aujourd'hui
au PO
sont fondamentalement différents
fondamentalement divergents un dernierot
non juste un mot pour ragir sur la
notion de majorité encomposition je
pense qu'elle est pas temp en
décomposition même si c'est difficile
qu'elle est tout simplement impossible
elle est impossible parce que les
résultats de l'élection législative en
2022 l'ont rendu fortement impossible à
à pratiquer c'est ça le vrai problème
aujourd'hui parce que on est déjà dans
une forme de guerre de succession et que
la guerre de succession fait que au-delà
même des idées il y a des intérêts allez
on va prendre un peu de recul sur cette
actualité vous savez le vendredi veille
de weekend on vous emmène découvrir les
traditions de notre patrimoine et en
cette veille de finale de Coupe du monde
de rugby direction évidemment le
Sud-Ouest si vous êtes fan de rugby ou
amateur de feria vous connaissez
forcément cette
chanson bah oui forcément Arnaud vous la
connaissez la peenia Bayona c'est
l'hymne du club de rugby de Bayonne et
c'est devenu en quelques années un
phénomène comme nous le raconte céil six
80000 voix
elles reprennent ton cœur la PEA Bayona
l'hyne des supporters de Bayon intupe
désormais mondialement connu mais d'où
vient-il festif et entraînant dans les
stades c'est dans l'intimité de ce local
à la battutee dans les Landes que le
morceau trouve son origine déniché par
cet homme pas tri desésine là on
cherchait des morceaux que les autres
groupes ne voent pas parce qu'ici il y a
déjà CIN ou si groupes musicaux qui se
tirent la Bour donc on on essayie
d'avoir toujours le dernier morceau ou
des nouveautés essayer d'amener des
nouveautés pour être copiêtre copié qu'
copieur il tombe un jour de
1992 sur une cassette enregistrée par un
groupe de musique espagnole il y avait
une quinzaine de morceaux dessus il y en
a trois qui m'ont flashé dont un qu'on
connaissait déjà qu'on cherchait depuis
longtemps mais on cherchait la version
originale pour pouvoir l'écrire qui
était dessus et en même temps on profité
d'en prendre deux autres donc dans ce
fameux
morceau ce morceau s'appelle le vino
Greco vin grec il vient en réalité
d'Autriche hudo Jurgen sorte de jouio
Iglesias germanque l'a écrit pour
raconter la nostalgie des Grecs émigrés
en Allemagne mais cétait comme ça n jou
comme ça aujourd'hui là é vachement
accéléré par rapport à
ça Patrick desine décide d'en faire un
des morceaux de son répertoire dans les
Landes le succès est viral au moment de
feria il a été beaucoup joué en course
landaise les écarteurs adoré ça et les
écarteurs il faut savoir qu'ils ont
toujours un morceau privilégié quand ils
écartent ils demandent nos musiqu
certains morceaux d'aren en arène c'est
parti c'est monté et c'est arrivé
partout ça ça dépassé les Landes c'est
arrivé au Paysbasque sûrement à Bayonne
à Bayon 10 ans après sa découverte dans
les Landes le morceau atterrit sur le
bureau de manèche Ming et ur de disque
les supportes du club de rugby lui
demandent d'en faire un hymne le
président de l'époque est venu me voir
avec deux ou trois copains à lui me dit
voilà on a on a envie de créer un hymne
pour la Viron mayonnais pour les
supporters de l'Aviron Bayonnais voilà
les paroles voilà la musique donc je dis
mais je la connais donc il y a pas de
problème on va faire tout ce qu'il faut
pour pour l'enregistrer il fait appel au
chanteur basque
gorcbless écoute le le morceau au casque
en studio et là il faut que ça colle
avec les paroles sauf qu'on s'est aperçu
ce jourl qu'il y avait plus de musique
que de parole donc c'est pour ça que la
fin du morceau c'est la je dit on va
faire le tour de lalala on va voir si ça
colle et c'est comme ça que dans la
version officielle la première Coltin il
y a tous c lalala à la fin c'est parce
qu'il y a pas assez de texte en fait les
lalalas sont adoptés tous les weekends
lors des matchs les bayonnés s'approprie
leur nouvelle symphonie ça commence à
l'entendre dans les tribunes et puis
surtout on l'entend repris pris par les
supporters des équipes adverses dans les
déplacements de la viriron et puis on
l'entend en dehors du stade de rugby
parce que c'est pris par le peuple en
fait qui commence à sarî cette chanson
d'hymne de club la peenia Bayona devient
un hymne du peuple chanté tous les ans
lors des fêtes de
Bayon jusqu'au Mondial de rugby cette
année un destin que n'avait pas imaginé
ceux qui l'ont découvert sorti un petit
village comme ça en morceau on est un
petit village habitant ici donc quand on
voit qu'on va jouer dans presqueemp dans
le monde entier alors qu' est sorti
d'ici est on est très fier très
content voilà ça donne envie de faire un
petit
[Rires]
paquitoite Benjamin il est
Chud on après
la
[Musique]
et Sam la une ce matin de nos journaux
régionaux on revient sur les annonces
d'éliizabeth B sur les violences
urbaines ça fait la Une de plusieurs
titres oui après les émeutes l'état
durcit le ton raconte ce matin pr océan
Rost sécuritaire titre aussi l'Alsace
encadrement des jeunes par l'armée stage
de responsabilité pour les parents
élargissement des pouvoirs de la police
municipale pour le journal alsacien les
réponses du gouvernement aux émeutes
urbaines sont d'abord je cite un copieux
catalogue de mesures d'ordre on parle
aussi du bio dans les cantines des
cantines pass bio regrette le Journal du
Centre la loi égalime votter en 2018 in
cité à proposer aux élèves au moins 50 %
de produits durables dont 20 % de bio
mais 5 ans plus tard on est loin du
compte rapporte le journal qui regrette
je cite que nos enfants et adolescents
continuent en majorité de trouver du
poulet issu d'élevage industriel dans
leurs assiettes laisse républicain
alerte sur les piscines municipales
l'état des piscines municipales oui les
piscines touchent le fond s'inquiète le
journal il y a 5 ans la cour des t
alerté déjà sur le modèle obsolète des
bassins municipaux tous déficitaires la
crise énergétique a encore aggravé le
problème puisqu'il faut bien
leséchauffer ces bassins résultat des
fermetures en cascade et ce sont les
enfants qui en paâtissent le plus à mes
par exemple il manque 1000 m² de bassin
pour que tous les élèves de la de la
métropole puissent avoir un créneau en
piscine sur le temps scolaire un
anniversaire un peu particulier ce matin
à la Une de La Dépêche oui les radars
automatique on 20 ans le tout premier il
avait été posé le 27 octobre 2003 à La
Ville du Bois dans lesesson il aé é
vandalisé attention 48 heur plus tard
seulement une tradition qui dure raconte
le journal après 20 ans d'existence le
radar automatique est toujours
controversé chaque année c'est quand
même 20 millions de conducteurs qui sont
flashés en moyenne et ça a déjà rapporté
12,5 milliards d'euros à l'État on
termine par la Transat jackabre qui fête
cette année ses 30 ans et pour célébrer
l'événement un grand feu d'artifice est
prévu ce soir au Havre c'est à la Une de
Paris Normandie ce matin merci Samia
merci beaucoup merci Benjamin merci
Arnaud merci à tous de nous d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi on vous
souhaite un très bon weekend avec peena
Bayona demain devant la finale de la
Coupe du monde de rugby très bon
weekend